When David Hyde Pierce confirmed that he wouldn't
be reprising his role on the rebooted "Frasier,"
fans were left wondering: What will happen
to Niles? Will he stay in Seattle? Or was he
unceremoniously killed off? A recent episode
of the reboot finally gave us an answer.
Fans of high-brow humor rejoiced when it was
announced that "Frasier" was coming back to
Paramount+. However, it wasn't all good news,
as it also came to light that David Hyde Pierce
would not reprise the part of Frasier's
brother, Niles, citing his desire not to
repeat the same old roles. However, Niles is
still an integral component of this universe,
so it only makes sense for the reboot to address
what happened to him and whether he's even alive.
"Frasier" viewers can rest
easy. Niles is still alive,
so the chance of at least a cameo materializing
in the new show is still on the table. However,
fans would be forgiven for wondering if
Niles bit the dust at some point because
the reboot has kept mum on what exactly went
down between him and Frasier. The new season
contains a moment when Olivia mentions a
sibling rivalry, to which Frasier responds:
"I am familiar with the dynamic."
Frasier's response could hint at the fact
that the two simply aren't on speaking terms,
which would explain why Niles isn't around
and why Frasier doesn't talk about him
much. But seeing how Frasier spends time with
Niles' son, David, and David hasn't mentioned
anything about his father passing away, it's
safe to say Niles is out there somewhere.
Given his status as a beloved sitcom character,
it also makes sense that Niles wouldn't be killed
off in the new "Frasier" series. While David
Hyde Pierce may not want to make a habit of
returning to old roles, he may be up for a small
appearance down the line. After all, the original
"Frasier" lasted for 11 seasons, so hopefully, the
revival will stick around for a while. However,
in the universe of the show, it's kind of sad to
think that Frasier and Niles are no longer close.
If Niles had died on "Frasier," the characters
could have moved on, but as it stands, there's
a huge hole missing on the rebooted series. And
now that Frasier is spending time with Niles' son,
it's even weirder if he never comes around.
The two could remain estranged within the
series if Pierce is adamantly against
returning, which would be a sad end for
the brothers. And it sort of shows how Frasier
can never make any familial relationships last.
The revival sees him move to Boston, mostly
so that he can reconnect with his own son,
Freddy. Frasier never had a chance to get
close to him before, and it may have come
at the expense of his relationship with
his brother taking a turn for the worse.
Of course, it would be incredibly
cathartic for fans to see Niles
again. The show could address why things may
have turned frosty between the brothers and
even see them reconcile. Niles doesn't
have to move to Boston with everyone,
but just one episode of Frasier and
Niles joking around would be delightful.
However, if you miss seeing Pierce on
screen, he has a new series to watch.
He stars as Paul Child in the series "Julia,"
streaming on Max. The 2022 drama covers the
fruitful life of American celebrity chef, Julia
Child. Season 2 premiered in November 2023,
but due to the ongoing SAG-AFTRA strike, you
likely haven't heard much about the series. So
now is a better time than ever to see how Pierce
portrays Julia's husband and creative partner,
as we wait to see what future
Niles has on the small screen.